olá tudo bem que vocês estão tudo bem
com vocês ainda mais alto por parte da
falada tudo bem com vocês pessoal
já meu nome é romário mora em são
gonçalo
meu nome é romário é por conta do
jogador meu nome romário porque o nome
do meu pai e marido da minha mãe
rosemary e juntou para romário
meu pai era flamenguista nunca colocaria
o nome do jogador na época do vasco
romário lateral esquerdo ainda no vasco
na época não teria como colocar isso pra
mim é colocar como arthur na casa zico
mas não deu para colocar enfim sou
flamenguista
estou muito feliz com alas de saída do
flamengo há pouco tempo também é a
saudações rubro negras eo pessoal sou
pai de matheus que infelizmente está
quase virando vascaína época dessa série
the oc também do meu time e trabalhar
para ganhar para ter uma agência de
comunicação que a gente pede serviço de
comunicação e investe na produção
cultural local
então a gente hoje faz esse trabalho mas
eu não vou me ater muito a isso é é uma
coisa triste pra voltar pra vocês que eu
não tenho nenhuma história triste nem
uma história emocionante
não inventei nada significativo para
poder deixar vocês muito felizes com a
minha falha você tem 15 minutos aí de
ouvir alguma coisa que também gera uma
reflexão mas que talvez não seja algo
tão relevante assim mas vamos tentar
contribuir é uma coisa que eu aprendi
muito nesse tempo trabalhando com
comunicação já oito anos é que a gente
fica muito preocupado em fazer contato
em nossa agenda de telefone em cheio o
nosso facebook de pessoas que muitas
vezes não vão contribuir para o nosso
processo de formação longo da nossa vida
e por algum motivo quando comecei a
trabalhar
eu percebi que eu estava muito mais
preocupado em fazer bons amigos do que
fazer bons contatos profissionais
então um fato de poder trabalhar da
maneira que eu quero do horário que eu
quero isso me ajudou muito na minha
formação e até mesmo tá aqui hoje eu
lembro que quando comecei a trabalhar
com comunicação minha primeira
experiência talvez mais próxima dela foi
na época do jornal da escola e aí as
pessoas perguntam por mar porque se
apropriou da escola que se queria
trabalhar com comunicação não porque se
queria escrever não é porque as meninas
bonitas estavam no jornal da escola
então a parte mais legal de ir pro
jornal era justamente essa
então isso foi por isso que comecei
é ele pra começar a falar sobre esse
processo de legitimação das práticas que
não são comuns ou não são formais ou não
tem uma demanda uma estrutura é já
cristalizadas
a gente precisa voltar a a metodologia e
fala sobre sócrates sócrates platão e
aristóteles que quando eles pensam na
formação de uma cidade na concepção de
uma cidade eles pensam em uma cidade
feita para todos para que cada pessoa
pudesse fazer o seu melhor naquela
cidade para que você fosse um único na
construção daquela cidade
então há dentro da mitologia com o seu
estômago
vamos lá a acidade né
ele pensa numa cidade em cada pessoa vai
ter a sua singularidade vai conseguir
fazer aquilo da melhor forma possível
infelizmente isso não é possível
hoje a gente tem uma estrutura em que a
cidade não é feita para as pessoas se
conectarem é com a seu prazer com seu
desejo hoje a cidade de todas elas são
feitas para conectar o capital ou
capital
hoje quando a gente pensa numa empresa
numa estrada em uma startup numa
universidade a maioria desses dessas
instituições elas estão muito mais
preocupadas em conectar o dinheiro ao
dinheiro e as pessoas não são tão
importantes
vou dar alguns exemplos aqui durante a
semana você consegue ter um transporte
público completamente conectado ao
capital para você trabalhar pra você é e
pelo emprego mesmo que você pega a
garrafa momento mas você tem ônibus pra
isso no final de semana que você
teoricamente tem um tempo livre não tem
uma boa mobilidade não está à sua
disposição então é uma cidade que é
muito mais preocupado em conectar o
dinheiro que conectar as pessoas é muito
fácil de repente você trabalhar você
mora em nova iguaçu trabalhar no centro
do rio
do que você por exemplo namorar alguém
que mora no centro do rio por conta da
distância então as grandes práticas de
trabalho de mercado de consumo são
possíveis de serem conectadas na cidade
que a gente vive hoje
já as conexões de prazer de
vejo que você dar um rolé de você se
divertir não são possíveis porque a
cidade não é feita para as pessoas então
você consegue trabalho de manhã mas se
você for uma boate à noite quiser voltar
para casa quatro horas da manhã
você vai ter problema para voltar agora
pra pegar até uberaba pegar o táxi vai
pagar mais caro do que isso então tem
uma uma uma circulação um pouco mais
dificultoso
e aí eu vou conectar essa pauta com a
periferia eu não vou entrar no caso do
rafael braga mas eu acho que é
importante vocês pesquisarem porque é um
caso importante pra gente pensar uma
cidade democrática na cidade para as
pessoas em uma cidade diferente
a periferia ela mesmo dentro de uma
cidade que é feita para conectar o
capital ela teve poucas oportunidades de
acessar plenamente esse capital teve
poucas oportunidades de acessar
plenamente o direito à cidade a ter
prazer então os piores empregos ou sub
emprego ficam com a periferia a o resto
do dinheiro o resto do lucro aconteceu e
nem o lucro chega mas há o dinheiro de
sobrevivência vai para a periferia e os
desejos autonomia e as oportunidades não
ficam por lá
esse é um exemplo rafael braga tentando
resumir sentindo bem breve rafael foi
preso duas vezes sem ter provas de que
eles estavam colocando como um
terrorista contra as manifestações que
ele estava por acaso lá com um pacote de
detergente não de é e prenderam ele já
pela segunda vez e ele está preso até
hoje
as pessoas ficam discutindo sobre a
justiça o poder judiciário poder
legislativo poder executivo sobre o
impeachment sobre as questões políticas
mais complexas do brasil sendo que a
gente tem hoje na periferia um caso que
talvez é muito mais brutal do que
qualquer problema do judiciário no
brasil e que também não é discutido qual
dessa maneira a aaa mesmo a lógica da
oportunidade da cidade capital ainda não
conecta a dificuldade da periferia com
essas questões mais complexas e aí não
falando dessa da escassez dos problemas
da periferia tanto levantar as potências
esse cara aqui com vários táxis e márcio
não deu para ver direito mas ele é um
amigo meu de são gonçalo
pagodeiro depois vão lá
o youtube procura março fé sai pra lá a
música boa é que ele ea periferia lá
sempre produziu muita coisa bacana ela
sempre teve uma forma de operar muito
própria a conexão arquitetura a produção
cultural a produção simbólica produção
material
ela sempre teve uma conexão muito
própria então há a potência da periferia
em criar uma maneira própria de
condições de viver e de se consolidar
também tem a ver com essa cidade que não
é feita para incluir a periferia é ela
ter que criar um mecanismo próprio de
administração e isso é uma grande
vocação da periferia porque ela própria
se legitimou a periferia ela passou a
entender que ela não precisa de alguém
vir falar com ela ouvir colonizar ela
pra ela sim se sentir potente sentir
criativa é e até um exemplo dessa
relação
ana paula tati chega sempre discutir
isso mas para a gente vai dar
e aí ela nunca foi em são gonçalo e
fazendo a cobrança para ela em são
gonçalo onde já de si para ela quando vi
o vídeo estava online lá uma parceira
minha mas enfim é só uma pausa nele pode
passar é voltando a legitimidade é a
legitimidade é uma péssima um debate
importante que eu faço porque sempre na
história do mundo era uma algum tipo de
elite ou algum grupo algum grupo
opressor chegando dentro das melhorias
outros grupos que não tinham tanta
estrutura querendo legitimar a prática
então os portugueses chegam no brasil
não legitimam os índios se e hoje a
gente tem uma estrutura uma colônia no
país
então legitimar as coisas é muito
fundamental para a gente poder entender
o poder de cada um e aí vou pegar a
periferia de novo é como exemplo que a
periferia ela não é legitimado pelo
resto da cidade não foi durante muito
tempo a periferia quando ela passa se
legitimar como uma prática potente como
um organismo potente ela consegue ter
essa autonomia começa a criar ainda mais
para além do seu gueto e consegue
ultrapassar essas barreiras né
como tem até a gíria do muro abaixo o
muro tendo baixo a gente consegue pode
maneira mais fácil
alguns exemplos sobre essas legitimações
gestão que a universidade está no espaço
importante de formação e sempre se faz o
debate sobre mobilidade urbana acho que
no rio de janeiro um debate super
importante inclusive quem mora em são
gonçalo niterói e baixada deve passar
perrengue para chegar na ufrj inclusive
e aí quando a gente vai ter essa
mobilidade
quando as pessoas começam a falar do que
fazem eu lembro muito desses últimos
movimentos disse que o ativista que
falam que estão discutindo mobilidade
dos grupos que vão discutir o trem que
discutem o metrô escutam ônibus mas
talvez a melhor prática de discussão de
mobilidade urbana hoje do país que
conseguiu resolver um problema de um
território completo foi o mototáxi
o mototáxi ele reinventa a maneira de
circulação na favela por um preço muito
mais barato do que todos esses essas
plataformas que tem aplicativo não muito
mais barato do que todo o setor público
e ela ainda é tirada como algo exótico o
mototáxi ele não precisa falar que ele
está fazendo discutindo mobilidade
urbana o mototáxi por si só ele já é uma
prática real da ação de gerar impacto
através da mobilidade
então quando a gente fala de
legitimidade justamente porque a gente
precisa cada vez mais aceitar e
legitimar as práticas não só pelo que
elas falam que são mas pelo que elas são
a sua natureza é outro debate que eu
faço é sobre o cabelo no tentar fazer
uma compra alguém sabe onde a praça são
salvador
alguém já rodou bambolê lá da rua do
bambolê
então é a praça são salvador é um
exemplo no rio de janeiro que as pessoas
dizem que estão ocupando espaço público
e o maior discurso às pessoas que
freqüentam então lá é nós estamos
ocupando espaço público e virou um case
hoje no rio de janeiro para são salvador
que se replicou para outros lugares
pessoas pegaram esse modelo como exemplo
de ocupação sendo que o camelô já faz
isso há muito tempo
o calorão o quadro espaço público já
milhares de anos e ele não é levado em
consideração como a gente que ocupa
espaço público porque ele não foi
legitimado ele não fala sobre o que ele
está fazendo então a importância de você
legitimar e aceitar com essas práticas
pelo que elas são
justamente pelo fato de que elas por si
só já ocupa um espaço público já
discutem mercado já discuta onde
discutem imposto
mesmo sem falar sobre isso não vê um
camelô para gente
vamos ocupar o espaço público amanhã o
melhor presidente vargas da ocupada de
espaço porque eles por si só já fazem
isso então a gente tentar entender que
as práticas da periferia e não só da
periferia mas de outros lugares também
por si só já falam muito mais as vezes
do que as práticas que precisam ser
narradas para contar uma história só uma
foto péssima minha cara quer que da
época de encontro de internet mas são
gonçalo quem foi no shopping são gonçalo
na frente do shopping são gonçalo a
saber que era
e aí eu um exemplo bacana de informação
que foi um processo interessante meu foi
justamente as palestras e as esquinas
jailton e dex hoje falou com a galera
maneira a gente boa e tal
só que as grandes conversas que eu tive
os grandes conselhos que eu tive foram
lugares que a fala ela não era o poder
de falar não era preciso ter um
privilégio era preciso ter um microfone
é preciso ter um palanque a gente pela
nossa conversa pelo nosso jeito de lidar
com as relações humanas
a gente já conseguia por si só criar um
campo de interação que a esquina era
potente acho que não precisa ser
programada para existir a esquina ela já
resolve o problema da comunicação entre
a gente e isso é um lugar também que a
gente precisa valorizar cada vez mais é
e com essa
com esse panorama todo traga a foto do
querido feliciano que a gente precisa
criar um um lugar uma cidade em que o
encontro dos diferentes gerem nova
igualdade a gente não pode aceitar que
as pessoas diferentes sejam tiradas como
pessoas ruins pessoas erradas
a gente precisa entender que a pessoa
que é diferente da gente ela criou uma
maneira nova de viver que a gente não
conseguiu
então quando eu tô vão tomar na rua que
eu vejo a um cara um motoqueiro 40 graus
todo de casaco preto e calça preta eu
acho que é isso eu acho que ele é um
cara muito corajoso de um jantar que ele
avatar para andando o centro da cidade
com aquele calor a gente tentar olhar
pessoa diferente como alguém que criou
uma nova maneira de viver
como uma nova maneira de experimentar na
vida e que a gente não conseguiu ser
aquilo
acho que é uma maneira muito bacana a
gente poder avançar nessa debate cidade
e eu trouxe dois exemplos pra cá que o
limites maiores limites à ismael tá aqui
até no palco - maior ele é o narrador
faz aí dança fazendo escolheu esperar
cristão é uma figura muito emblemático
empreendedor tem uma loja de covent boné
tem uma produtora de vídeo e ainda por
cima o que é um por cento há ainda deve
mais menina por aí
o livro empreendedor caroline por si só
é um ataque empreende é um moleque de 18
anos que está empreendendo diariamente é
um cara que o startup que o empreendedor
- que uma empresa social e que não
precisa ficar falando que ele faz
só que a gente vive num mundo em que as
pessoas precisam ficar falou olha meu
negócio social
eu estou praticando um empreendedorismo
bem estou criando um impacto ele já faz
isso você não precisa falar isso isso é
bacana a gente pode olhar diferente como
você poder ter um ponto de criar essas
experiências e um deve voltar pra cá o
evento quinta que é um professor vamos
lá vocês entenderem um aluno vitor que
tem uma música que só né
o victor é da aula de história de
literatura de química de matemática de
física de teologia e filosofia por um
pré vestibular que tem 400 alunos
eu tenho uma proposta de 80 processos
por ano para cursos de engenharia
direito é então ele é um absurdo
o vitor ele tem uma história montou um
projeto chamado tanta gente que trabalha
com impacto social e territórios
povoados e ele não é reconhecido como um
cara importante da educação no rio de
janeiro coloca
[Música]
usando na universidade pública o cara
tem um trabalho gigantesco de publicação
de livro de trabalho com um combate de
boxe popó semana estimado como deveria
ser um campo da educação
então sou exemplo que vocês verem que
não precisa ficar falando do seu próprio
trabalho pra você gera impacto para você
ser um cara potente só comprando da sua
produção
e pra finalizar já tentara concluindo
aqui de sinal tem boas coisas exemplo é
a primeira queria mandá los ao pormenor
da favela que eles falaram que eu falei
pra ele que ele dizia da palestra mudar
a maneira de criar para não sabe se lá
no youtube mulher que montou a fila do
mundo sejam salvos para vocês aí
[Aplausos]
eu não sei quem vai jogar mas é preciso
discutir não só ficar falando trocando
idéias mas preciso repensar é que país
que a gente está e eu pessoalmente muito
incomodado com a extinção do ministério
da cultura porque se não fosse o
ministério da cultura ao longo da minha
vida os programas que eu participei das
pessoas que eu conheci através desse
ministério eu não estaria aqui eu
estaria vivendo de produção total e
comunicação
então não tem como você os frutos e e
pra finalizar morreu há pouco tempo era
um produtor de cachaça de pagar com os
casos mais importante pra religiões de
matrizes africanas da região e
infelizmente ele não vai ter nenhum
discurso presidencial ou não na casa dos
tios uma pessoa e levantou não é eu
queria trazer essa memória dele pra cá
pra gente poder bater palma pra ele é um
cara muito importante pra mim pra
cultura da região mas fornece a wisco
dispensa desculpa qualquer coisa ea
imagem
[Aplausos]